so Brandon this is a great point because
I think there are a lot there are a lot
of conservatives a lot of folks on the
right who feel that myself included by
the way who feel that Republicans have
been largely useless you know you look
at the last two years and you say Well
when mandates were instituted where were
Republicans oftentimes you feel like
Republicans are holding hands with those
big machines like big Pharma for example
the big time lobbyists they're holding
hands with all the same people that the
Democrats are holding hands with and
that a lot of what comes out of their
mouths is like a phony interest in
reducing the national debt a phony
interest in preserving freedom and
people can only look to like Rand Paul
and Mike Lee and a few people here and
there that they can count on but the
party at large is useless so what is
your take on a third party and what is
your take what do you say to people who
say like I'm fed up with both sides of
the aisle
well I'd say uh third party will
probably never happen
um but I do understand how people are
fed up with both sides because I am too
man these Republicans and some of them
is a whacking in the Democrats
um at least some of them at least the
Democrats you know where they're
standing in most cases but some of these
Republicans they're so fickle you don't
really know where they stand they're
just Republican in name only they don't
have any actions because that are
conservative or related to the
Republican party and what the Republican
Party should be however I will say that
it's worth us overtaking the Republican
party and creating an environment in
which is going to be conducive for our
country Donald Trump was one of the
first uh I guess people to to be
interjected into the Republican party
that wasn't a part of the Republican
establishment he wasn't a part of the
guys who argue on the floor of Congress
and then they go have drinks together at
a bar and laugh at us you know so I
think Donald Trump was the first wave
you you got other politicians that are
jumping in there
um the younger guys younger women who
are coming forth and saying look we're
going to stand up for American values
and we're going to stand up for
Religious Freedom we're going to fight
against our own party if we have to you
know uh right here in the state of
Arizona you know you have what they call
uh McCain rhinos of people who are just
a part of the establishment they hate
Trump but you know there's a wave of
people that are saying I'm sick of y'all
too because we love what Trump did we
may not like all his tweets and
everything he do he talk in circles
sometimes but however his policies are
effective and you've seen it here in the
midterms that so many Trump endorsed
candidates are winning and so I think
that our focus should be let's re we
don't have to recreate the wheel let's
just you know get more of the Republican
type people that we trust into office
and then we can phase out the ones who
we do not trust but to think that we're
going to have a third party is nearly
impossible because a lot of people what
we call low information voters some
people are just dedicated to the
Republican party I mean Hitler could run
as a Republican and people wouldn't care
they'll just vote Republican the same
thing for the Democrats I mean Democrats
are pushing socialism Marxism and and
people in that have escaped some of
these places are still voting for them
yeah they hate Christians they hate God
and not all of them but I'm saying
generally speaking as a as a party they
hate God and then you have people who
are Christians still voting for them so
some people are low information voters
they're going to vote for whatever party
they like we might as well infiltrate
the party and do what's right and I'll
say this last one uh this one point I
think conservatives should not be afraid
to run as Democrats in certain areas let
me let me say why in California you will
never get anywhere as a republican in
most places in California you'll never
get anywhere however the Republican
message is actually good and the
Republican mixtures message actually
identifies or people can identify with
it they just will never hear from a
republican because they've been
brainwashed to believe that Democrats is
the only way so some people that that
may not have run for politics before if
they come into it with a good message
and they put D next to their name it's a
possibility that they may get some votes
in some of these other places we've seen
Democrats do it in Republican places as
well and that's where we get the term
rhinos these people are really Democrats
but they know they can only give votes
if they have an R next to their name if
you want to watch the full episode
you're going to click right here and if
you want to ask me a question one on one
you want to do a one-on-one face time
with a group of your friends whatever
you want you need to download minute
right now click right here and let's get
talking
foreign
[Music]